Before we begin, make new of
Ran and Excent Res
[music]
now. I seek refuge in God from Satan, the accursed. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful.
Praise be to God, Lord of the worlds, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful,
Master of the Day of Judgment. You alone we worship, and You alone we ask for help.
Guide us to the straight path, the path of those upon whom
You have bestowed favor, not of those who have evoked [Your] anger or of those who are astray.
In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. Alif, Lam, Mim. This is the
Book about which there is no doubt, a guidance for those conscious of God - those who believe in
the unseen, establish
prayer, and spend out of what We have provided for them, and
those who believe in what has been revealed to you, [O Muhammad], and what was revealed
before you, and of the Hereafter they are certain.
Those are upon [right] guidance from their Lord, and it is those who are the successful. Indeed, those who disbelieve - it is all the same for them
whether you
warn them or do not warn them - they will not believe. God has set a seal
upon their hearts and upon their hearing, and over their vision is a veil. And for them is a
great punishment. And among the people are some who say, "We believe in God and in the
Last Day," but they are not
believers. They [think to] deceive God and those who believe, but they deceive not except
themselves and perceive [it] not.
In their hearts is disease, so God has increased their disease;
and for them is a painful punishment for what they [used to do].
They lie, and when it is said to them, “Do not cause corruption on the earth,” they say, “
We are only
reformers.” Unquestionably, it is they who are the corrupters, but they do not perceive it. And when it is
said to them, “Believe as the people have believed,” they say, “Shall we believe as the foolish have believed?” Unquestionably, it is they who are the
foolish, but they do not
know. And when they meet those who believe, they say, “We believe.”
But when they turn to
their devils, they say, “Indeed, we are with you.” They say, “Indeed, we are with you; we were only mocking.”
God mocks them and prolongs them in their transgression while they wander blindly.
Those are the ones who have purchased error [in exchange] for guidance,
so their transaction has brought no profit, nor were they
guided. Their example is like that of one who kindled a fire, but when it
illuminated what was around him, God took away their light and left them in
darkness, unable to
see. Deaf, dumb, and blind, so they will
not
return [to the right path]. Or [their example is] like a rainstorm from
the sky within which is darkness,
thunder, and lightning. They put their fingers in their ears against the
thunderclaps, fearing death. And God
encompasses
the disbelievers. The lightning almost snatches away
their sight. Every time it flashes for them, they
walk in it; but when darkness comes over them, they stand still. And
if God willed, He could take away their hearing and
their sight. Indeed, God is over all things.
O mankind, worship your Lord, who
created you and those before you, that you may become righteous. He
who made for you the earth a bed and
the sky a canopy and sent down
rain from the sky and brought forth thereby
fruits as provision for you. So
do not attribute to Allah equals while you know [that there is nothing like Him]. And if you are
in doubt about what We have revealed to
Our servant, then produce a chapter like it and call upon your witnesses. And call upon your witnesses
other than Allah, if you should be
truthful. But if you do not—and you will never be able to—then fear the
Fire whose fuel is men and
stones, prepared for the
disbelievers. And give good tidings to those who believe and do righteous
deeds that they will have gardens [in Paradise] beneath which
rivers flow. Whenever they are provided with a provision of fruit therefrom,
they will say, “This is what we were provided with before.” And they will be given things
resembling it. And they will have therein
purified spouses, and they will abide therein eternally. Indeed,
Allah is not ashamed to present an example—
some of it or
more. And as for those who believe, they know that it is the truth
from their Lord.
But as for those who disbelieve, they say, “What did Allah intend by this
example?” He misleads many thereby and guides many thereby. And He misleads not
except the defiantly disobedient.
Those who break the covenant of God after
its confirmation and sever what
God has commanded to be joined and spread corruption on earth - it is they who are the
losers. How can you disbelieve in God when you were lifeless and He gave you life; then He will cause you to die, then He will give you life again; then to Him you will be returned? He is the One who
created for
you all that is on the earth. Then He turned
to the heaven and fashioned them into
seven
heavens. And He is All-Knowing of everything. And when your Lord said to
the angels, “Indeed, I will make upon the earth a
successor,” they said, “Will You place upon it one who causes corruption therein and
sheds
blood, while we exalt You with praise and declare Your holiness?” He said, “Indeed, I know that which you do not
know.” And He taught Adam
all the names. Then He presented them to the angels and said, “Inform Me of the names of
these, if you are
truthful.” They said, “Exalted are You! We have no knowledge except what You have
taught us. Indeed, it is You who is the All-Knowing, the All-Wise.” He said, “O
Adam,
inform them of
their names.” And when he informed them of
their names, He said, “Did I not tell you that I know the unseen [aspects] of
the heavens and the earth? And I know what you reveal and what you
conceal.” When We said to the angels, “Prostrate to Adam,” they prostrated
except to God.  Iblis disobeyed and was arrogant and became one of the
disbelievers. And We said, "O Adam, dwell, you and your wife, in
Paradise and eat freely from it wherever you wish. But do not approach
this tree, lest you be among the
wrongdoers." Then Satan caused them to slip from it and removed them from that [condition] in which they had been. And We said, "
Descend, some of you
enemies to others, and you will have upon the earth a place of settlement and enjoyment for a time." Then
Adam received from his Lord words [of revelation], and He accepted his repentance. Indeed, He is the Accepting of Repentance, the
Merciful. We said, "Descend from it, all of you. And
if there comes to you guidance from Me, then whoever
follows My guidance - there will be no fear concerning them,
nor will they
grieve. But those who disbelieve and deny
Our verses - those are the companions of the Fire; they will abide therein eternally." O
Children of Israel, remember My favor which
I have bestowed upon you and fulfill My
covenant. And I will fulfill your covenant, and fear Me [alone].
And believe in what I have revealed confirming that which is with you and do not
be the first to disbelieve in it. And do not exchange My verses for a
small price, and fear Me [alone]. And
do not mix the truth with falsehood or conceal the
truth while you
know [it]. And establish prayer and give [your prayers]  And give zakat and
bow down with those who
bow down. Do you enjoin righteousness upon the people and
forget
yourselves while you recite the
Scripture? Then will you not reason?
And seek help through patience and prayer. Indeed,
it is difficult except for the
humble, who are certain that they will meet their Lord and
that to Him they will
return. O Children of Israel, remember My favor which
I bestowed upon you and that I preferred you over
the worlds. And fear a Day when no soul will avail another soul at
all, nor will intercession be accepted from it, nor will compensation be taken from it,
nor will they be aided. And [remember] when
We delivered you from the people of Pharaoh, who were afflicting you with the
worst torment, slaughtering your sons and sparing your
women. And in that was a
great trial from your Lord. And [remember] when We parted the sea for you and saved you and drowned the people of
Pharaoh while you were
looking on. And [remember] when We made an appointment with Moses for forty nights. Then you took the
calf [for worship] after him while you were wrongdoers.
Then He pardoned you after that so that you might be
grateful. And [remember] when We
gave Moses the Scripture and the Criterion so that you might be
guided. And [remember] when Moses said to his people, "O my people, indeed you have
wronged yourselves."  You worshipped the calf, so repent, so repent to
your Creator and kill yourselves.
That is better for you in the sight of your Creator. Then He accepted your repentance; indeed, He is the Accepting of Repentance, the
Merciful. And when you said, "O Moses, we will not
believe you until we see God outright," the thunderbolt struck you while you were
looking on. Then We revived you
after your death so that you might be grateful. And We shaded you with clouds and sent
down to you manna and quails. [We said], "
Eat of the good things with which We have
provided you." And they did not wrong Us, but they
wronged themselves. And when We said, "Enter this city and eat freely from
wherever you wish, and enter the gate bowing humbly
and say, 'Repentance,' We will forgive you
your sins and increase the reward for the doers of good." But those who wronged changed the
word to something other than what was
said to them, so We sent down upon those who wronged a punishment from
the sky because they were defiantly disobedient. And when Moses prayed for water for his people,
We said, "Strike the rock with your staff," and there gushed forth from it
twelve springs. Each people knew
its drinking place. [We said], "Eat and drink from the provision of God and do not
commit abuse on the earth."  And
when you said, “O Moses, we will not endure
one kind of food. So call upon your Lord to bring forth for us some of what the earth produces—its
herbs, its cucumbers, its garlic, its lentils, and
its onions,” he said, “Would you exchange what is better for what is worse? Go down to the desert, for there you will find what you asked for.” And they were covered with
humiliation and misery, and
they incurred the wrath of God. That was because they used to
disbelieve in the verses of God and
kill the prophets
unjustly. That was because they disobeyed and were transgressors. Indeed, those who believe—those who believe—and
those who are Jews and Christians and Sabeans—whoever believes in
God and the Last Day and does righteousness—
they will have their reward with their Lord, and there will be no
fear concerning them, nor will they grieve. And when We took
your covenant and raised it above you, [saying], “Take what We have given you
with determination and remember what is in it that you may become righteous.”
Then
you turned away after that. And if not for the favor of God upon you and His mercy,
you would have been among the
losers. And you had already known about those among you who transgressed concerning the
Sabbath, so We said to them, “Be apes.”  Disgraced,
we made it an example for those before and after it and a
lesson for the righteous. And when Moses said to his people, “Indeed,
Allah commands you to slaughter a cow,” they said, “Do you take us in mockery?” He said, “I seek refuge in Allah
from being among
the ignorant.” They said, “Call upon your Lord to make clear to us what it is.” He said, “He says, ‘It is a
cow neither old nor young, but of middle
age between that. So do as you are
commanded.’” They said, “Call upon your Lord to make clear to us what
its color is.” He said, “He says, ‘It is a
yellow cow, bright in color, that will dazzle the onlookers.’”
They said, “Call upon your Lord to make clear to us what it is. Indeed,
the cow is similar to us, and we, if Allah wills, will be
guided.” He
said, “He says, ‘It is a cow neither trained to plow the
earth nor to water the wells, sound and without blemish.’”
They said, “Now you have come with the truth.” So they slaughtered it, though they were reluctant to
do so. And when you killed a soul and disputed over it, but Allah was to bring out that which you
were
concealing, We said, “Strike him with a part of it.” Thus does
Allah bring the dead to life, and He shows you His signs so that you might
understand. Then your hearts hardened after that, so they are like stones
or even harder.  And indeed, there are
stones from which
rivers burst forth, and there are some that split open and
water flows from them, and there are some that fall down for fear of God. And
God is not unaware of what you do. Do you then
expect them to believe you when a
group of
them used to hear the word of
God, then
distort it after they had understood it, while they
knew. And when they meet those who believe, they say, "We believe," but when they are alone with one another, they say, "Do you tell them what God has revealed to you so that they may argue with you about it
before
your Lord? Do you not understand?" Do they not know
that God knows what they conceal and what they
reveal? And among them are unlettered ones who do
not know the Scripture except through wishful thinking, and they do nothing but assume. So woe to those who
write the Scripture with their own hands,
then say, "This is from God," to exchange it for a
small price. Woe to them for what their hands have written and woe to them for what they earn. And they
say, "The Fire will not touch us except for a few days."
Say, "Have you taken a covenant with God? God will never break His covenant.
Or do you say about God what you do not
know?" Yes, whoever earns evil and is encompassed by his sin - those are the first to be punished.
Those are the companions of the Fire; they will abide therein eternally. And
those who believe and do righteous deeds -
those are the companions of
Paradise; they will abide therein eternally.
And [recall] when We took the covenant from the Children of Israel, [enjoining upon them], “Do not
worship except Allah; and to parents do good; and to relatives, orphans, and
the needy. And
speak good words to people and
establish prayer and
give zakah.” Then you turned away, except a few of you, while
you were refusing. And [recall] when We took your covenant, [enjoining upon them], “Do not shed one another’s
blood or expel one another
from your homes.” Then you acknowledged [it] while you were witnessing. Then you are those [who do so], killing one
another and expelling a
group of you
from their homes, supporting one another against them in sin and transgression. And if they come to you as captives, you ransom them, while it is
forbidden for you to
expel them. So do you believe in part of the
Scripture and disbelieve in part? Then what is the recompense for those who
do that among you except disgrace in
worldly life; and on the Day of Resurrection they will be sent back to the severest
punishment. And Allah is not unaware of what you
do. Those [are the companions of Paradise]  Those who have purchased the life of this world at the price of the Hereafter - their punishment will
not be lightened, nor will they be
helped. And We gave Moses the Scripture and followed him with
messengers. And We gave Jesus, the son of Mary, clear proofs and
supported him with the Holy Spirit. So is it that whenever a messenger comes to you with what your souls do
not desire, you become arrogant? And a group [of them] you deny, and a group you kill. And they
say, "Our hearts are behind [the truth]." Rather, God has cursed them for their disbelief, so little do they believe. And when there
came to them a Book from God confirming
what was with them - and they used to seek
victory before - and they used to seek victory before - over
those who disbelieved - but when there came to them that which they recognized, they disbelieved in it. So God has
cursed the disbelievers. Wretched is that for which they sold themselves - that they would disbelieve in what
God has revealed, out of envy that
God should send down of His bounty upon whom He wills of
His servants. So they incurred wrath upon wrath. And for the disbelievers is a
humiliating punishment. And when it is said to them, "Believe in what God has revealed,"
they say, "We believe in what was revealed to us," and they disbelieve in what is
beyond it, while it is the truth confirming what was with them. Say, "Then why did you
kill the prophets of God before, if you were  Believers.
And Moses came to you with clear proofs. Then you took the calf
after him, while you were wrongdoers. And when We took your covenant
and raised the mountain above you, [We said], "Take what We have given
you with determination and listen."
They said, "We have heard and disobeyed." And the calf was instilled in their hearts by their disbelief.
Say, "How evil is that which your faith commands you to do, if you are believers." Say, "If the Hereafter with
God is exclusively for you, excluding other people, then
wish for death, if you should be
truthful." But they will never wish for it, because of what their hands have put forth. And God is Knowing of the
wrongdoers. And you will surely find them the most
greedy of people for life, even more than those who
associate others with God. One of them would wish to live a thousand years, but it would not remove him
from the punishment. And God is Seeing of what they
do. Say, "Whoever is an enemy to Gabriel - for indeed, he has brought it down
upon your heart, [O Muhammad], by permission of God, confirming what was before it and as guidance and good tidings for
the believers." Whoever is an enemy to God and
His angels and His messengers and Gabriel - then indeed, God is an enemy to
the disbelievers. And We have certainly sent down to you
clear verses. And none disbelieves in them except the defiantly
disobedient.  They made a covenant, but a group of them rejected it; indeed,
most of them do not
believe. And when a messenger came to them from God, confirming what was
with them, a group of those who were given the Scripture cast the
Book of God behind their backs as if they did not
know it. And they followed what the devils recited concerning the kingdom of
Solomon. And Solomon did not disbelieve, but the devils
disbelieved, teaching people magic and that which was revealed to the two angels in
Babylon, Harut and
Marut. And they do not teach anyone until they say, “We are only a trial, so do
not disbelieve.” And
they learn from them that by which they cause separation between a man and
his wife. But they do not harm anyone through it
except by permission of
God. And they learn what harms them and does not
benefit them. And they have already known that whoever buys it will have no share in the
Hereafter. And how wretched is that for which they sold
themselves, if only they
knew. And if they had believed and feared God, the reward
from God would have been better, if only they knew.
O you who have believed, do not say, “
Ra’ina,” but say, “Unzurna,” and listen. And for the disbelievers is a
painful punishment. Neither those who disbelieve
among the People of the Scripture nor the polytheists like that any
good should be sent down to you from your
Lord. But God selects for His
mercy whom He
wills, and God is the possessor of
great bounty.  We do not abrogate or cause to be forgotten a verse except that We bring forth something better
than it or
similar to it. Do you not know that God is All-Powerful over everything? Do you
not know that to God belongs the dominion of the heavens
and the earth,
and you have no protector or helper besides God? Or do
you intend to question your Messenger as Moses was questioned
before? And whoever exchanges disbelief for faith has certainly strayed from the right path.
Many of the People of the Scripture wish they could turn you back to disbelief
after you have believed, out of envy. They wish they could turn you back to disbelief out of envy of
their own souls after the truth has become clear to them.
So pardon and overlook until God brings about
His command. Indeed, God is All-Powerful over everything. And establish prayer and give zakah and whatever good you put forward for yourselves - you will find it with God. Indeed, God is Seeing of what you do. And they say, "None will enter Paradise except one who is a Jew or a Christian." Those are their [own] desires. Say, "Produce your proof, if you should be
truthful." Yes, whoever submits himself to God while being a doer of good - then his
reward is with his Lord, and there will be no fear concerning them, nor will they
grieve. And the Jews say, "The Christians have nothing [of truth] to stand on," and the
Christians say, "The Jews have nothing [of truth] to stand on," while they
recite the
Scripture. Thus say those who do not know.  Like
their saying, “Allah will judge between them on the Day of Resurrection concerning that over which they used to
differ.” And who is more unjust than one who prevents the name of Allah from being
mentioned in His mosques and strives toward
their destruction? It was not for them to enter them except in
fear. For them in this world is disgrace, and for them in the Hereafter is a
great punishment. And to Allah belong
the east and
the west. So if they turn away, then there is the Face of Allah. Indeed, Allah is All-Encompassing and All-Knowing. And they said, “Allah has taken a son.” Exalted is He! Rather, to Him belongs whatever is
in the heavens and the earth. All belongs to Him. He is the Originator of the
heavens and the earth.
And when He decrees a matter, He only says to it, “Be,” and it is. And those who do
not know say, “Why does
Allah not speak to us or there come to us a sign?” Likewise, those
before them said similar things. Their hearts are alike. We have made clear the signs for a people who believe. Indeed,
We have sent you with the truth as a bringer of good tidings and a warner. And you will not be
asked about the companions of Hellfire. And the
Jews and the Christians will never be pleased with you until you follow
their religion. Say, “Indeed, the guidance of Allah is the [only] guidance.” And if you were to follow
their desires after what has come to you of knowledge, you would have against
Allah no protector or helper. Those to whom We gave
the Scripture recite it as it should be recited.
They are the ones who believe in it. And whoever disbelieves in it...
Those are the
losers. O Children of Israel, remember My favor
which I bestowed upon you and that I preferred you over all the
worlds. And fear a Day when no soul will avail another soul at
all, nor will compensation be accepted from it, nor will intercession benefit it,
nor will they be aided. And when
Abraham's Lord tested him with commands, and he fulfilled them, He said, "Indeed,
I have made you a leader for the people." He said, "And from
my descendants?" He said, "None of the wrongdoers will attain [the truth]." And when We made the
House a place of return for the people and a sanctuary. And take, [O believers], from the standing place of
Abraham a place of prayer. And We charged Abraham and Ishmael, "Purify My House for those who circumambulate it and those who remain therein for worship and those who bow and prostrate."
And when Abraham said, "My Lord, make this a
secure city and provide its people with fruits - whoever of them believes in
Allah and the Last Day." He said, "And whoever disbelieves - I will grant him
enjoyment for a little while; then I will force him to the punishment of the Fire, and wretched is the destination." And
when Abraham and Ishmael were raising the foundations of the House, [they prayed], "Our Lord,
accept [this] from us. Indeed You are the All-Hearing, the All-Knowing. Our
Lord, and make us Muslims [in submission] to You and from our descendants a
Muslim nation [in submission] to You. And show us our rites and accept our repentance. Indeed
You are the Accepting of Repentance, the
Merciful. Our Lord  And send among them a messenger from themselves who will recite
to them Your verses and teach them the Book and wisdom and
purify them. Indeed, You are the Exalted in Might, the Wise. And who would turn away from the religion of Abraham except one who has made
himself a fool? And We have
chosen him in this
world, and indeed, in the Hereafter he will be among the
righteous. When his Lord said to him, “Submit,” he said, “I have submitted to the Lord of
the worlds.” And Abraham enjoined upon his sons and
Jacob, “O my sons, indeed Allah has chosen for you this religion, so do not
die except while
you are
Muslims.” Or were you
witnesses when death approached Jacob, when he said to his sons, “What will
you worship after me?”
They said, “We will worship your God and the God of your fathers, Abraham,
Ishmael, and Isaac - one God. And we are
Muslims [in submission] to Him.” That was a nation which has passed on. It will have [the consequence of] what it earned, and you will have what you earn. And you will
not be questioned about what they used to do. And
they said, “Be Jews or Christians under [your] hand.” Say, “Rather, [we follow] the religion of
Abraham, inclining toward truth, and he was not of
the polytheists.” Say, “We believe in Allah and in what was revealed to us and what was revealed
to Abraham,
Ishmael, Isaac, Jacob, and the
Descendants, and in what was given to Moses and Jesus and what was given to the
prophets from their Lord. We make no distinction
between any of them, and we are Muslims [in submission] to Him.”  If they believe as
you believe, then they are rightly guided. But if they turn away, then they are only
in
dissension. So Allah will suffice you against them. And He is the All-Hearing, the All-Knowing. Allah has dyed it, and
who is better than Allah in
dyeing it? And we are His
worshippers. Say, "Do you argue with us
about Allah while He is our Lord and your Lord? For us are our
deeds and for you are your deeds, and we are sincere to Him. Or do
you say that Abraham, Ishmael, Isaac, Jacob, and
the Tribes were Jews or
Christians?" Say, "Are
you more knowing than
Allah? And who is more unjust than one who conceals a testimony he has from
Allah? And Allah is not unaware of what
you do. That was a nation which has passed on. It will have what it
earned, and you will have what you earn. And you will
not be questioned about what they used to do."
[Music]